Now, look at your page and compare it to the design mock and
make sure that you go deeper than just a simple visual check.
See if the defining parts are correct.
The layout, margins, fonts, colors, etc.
For example,
does the image in the mock up look different than the image on your page?
In comparing the two,
you can see that there's actually a space here and we dont' have a space here.
You can use Dev Tools to find the proper value of the margin for
the image class.
Once you've refined it in Dev Tools, you can then save it to your CSS file.
You can look to the design mock to find this information.
The background and color for the title is also incorrect.
Now, often these colors are provided within the design document and
you can see these small boxes on the left-hand side and
the color in a hex code is defined there.
But you can also use different color-picker tools to get the same information.
As you refine the design, answer the following questions, first,
what margin size gets the design closer to the mock?
Also, what is the background color for the header?